will there be a meatless burger in your
future it's not impossible in 2018 total
sales of substitute meat products were
already estimated to be about 4.5
billion dollars and McDonald's recently
announced that it will test market a
burger that uses plant proteins instead
of beef but going forward companies like
beyond meat may have trouble finding the
dry peas they need to make patties the
good news 1.1 million acres were planted
in 2019 the bad news switching from
traditional crops to dry peas will
involve equipment changes and may
require some farms to gain experience
working with the new crop adding costs
and time and another barrier exists for
companies that insist on using organic
Peas under current USDA rules it takes
three years to qualify land to raise
certified organic crops but it all goes
well plant-based meat sales could double
by 2024 and might account for 20% of all
meat sales in a few decades would you
buy it fast food meatless burger let us
know in our poll also let us know
whatever topics you would like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI